herzlich willkommen so einen neuen hallo
deutschland woche schön dass sie mit
dabei sind und wir starten die sendung
mit einem corona kompakt mit den
neuesten tages aktuellen entwicklungen
ein ganzer ort in thüringen steht unter
quarantäne
seit gestern abend dürfen 900 einwohner
aus neustadt am rennsteig nur noch rein
und nicht mehr raus es gibt sechs
infizierte das gesundheitsamt ermittelte
69 kontaktpersonen
deshalb hat die landrätin den ort unter
quarantäne gestellt die feuerwehr
bewacht die zufahrten per videotelefon
erreichen wir heute den bürgermeister
des ortes
auch er arbeitet im home office und
versucht von dort aus zum beispiel die
medikamentenversorgung für alle bewohner
zu organisieren
da ist auch folgten durch freiwillige
das verteilen der medikamente haben die
bürgerinnen und bürger die neuen
bundesweiten anordnungen sind am
hamburger hauptbahnhof kaum einzuhalten
ein meter fünfzig mindestabstand kontakt
mit maximal einer person außerhalb des
eigenen hausstands an vielen orten der
republik beobachten unsere reporter
heute die menschen ziehen sich weiter
zurück mein eindruck ist ja es ist
deutlich weniger los jetzt haben
alexanderplatz hinter mir da kreuzen
sich zwei hauptstraßen und schon den
berufsverkehr war hier einfach weniger
an autos weniger menschen in bus und
bahn
wenn sie hinter mich schauen das ist
hier der marienplatz in münchen
das ist ein platz auf dem sie
normalerweise um diese zeit hunderte von
menschen um etwa dem glockenspiel zu
lauschen hier ist im grunde genommen
ganz vereinzelt nur sind hier leute zu
sehen
schlange stehen heißt es inzwischen an
den eingängen von vielen supermärkten
hier darf ein kunde nur noch rein sobald
ein anderer den laden verlassen hat der
anstieg der infizierten zahl hat sich
etwas verlangsamt
heute nachmittag gab es laut johns
hopkins universität 26 1220 infizierte
in deutschland
damit blieb der anstieg unter dem
bisherigen höchstwert von freitag
422 menschen haben die krankheit
inzwischen überstanden
bei mir ist jetzt der attacke unsere
leiterin der zdf-hauptredaktion sarah
seit heute soll man nur noch zu zweit
rausgehen oder eben als familie was
passiert denn wenn ich mich an diese
regel nicht halte das gilt für alle
menschen in deutschland denn diese
bußgelder und strafen die es da geben
kann sind im bundes
infektionsschutzgesetz geregelt und geld
damit für das gesamte land und sie
drohen bußgelder bis zu 25.000 euro oder
auch eine freiheitsstrafe bis zu zwei
jahre
man muss aber sagen das ist jetzt nicht
bei einem einmaligen verstoßen da muss
man schon hartnäckiger
wiederholungstäter sein damit er
wirklich die maximalstrafen kommen aber
es können harte strafen seien und
wichtig ist auch unwissenheit schützt
vor strafe nicht also man kann sich
nicht herausreden sowieso schwer in
dieser kürze muss sagen ich wusste von
nichts
da kann man sich nicht ausgehen muss
schauen was geht in meinem bundesland
muss ich mich konkret verhalten und sich
dementsprechend verhalten weil auch
fahrlässiges fahrlässiger regelverstoß
bestraft werden kann
okay das ist ordentlich du bleibst noch
da vielen dank und gleich reden wir
nochmal mit unserer rechtsexperten das
sonntagsfahrverbot geht nicht mehr und
damit sind lkw-fahrer ununterbrochen im
corona liefer einsatz großes problem
dabei auch die raststätten sind
geschlossen es gibt immer weniger dusch-
oder es möglichkeiten für die trucker
und die hygiene in den toiletten häusern
die ist teilweise katastrophal wenn lkw
fahrern einer raststätte anhalten dann
stehen sie meistens vor verschlossenen
türen
die landesweiten verordnungen das
speiselokale und gaststätten schließen
müssen haben dazu geführt dass auch die
rastanlagen komplett geschlossen werden
die lkw fahrer schauen in die röhre
oder sie denn bei den cologne ab wie die
gerne machen wenn alle sich zu und wenn
etwas offen ist dann werden diese
anlagen geradezu überrannt zwar
versuchen die fahrer sich so gut es geht
zu schützen
aber die hygienischen bedingungen sind
für alle katastrophal
es scheint paradox die lkw-fahrer werden
mehr denn je gebraucht und fühlen sich
doch mehr denn je im stich gelassen
der bundesverband güterkraftverkehr
bemüht sich um eine lösung und stellt
ganz klare forderungen wir fordern ein
bis zwei stunden täglich zusätzliche
menge zeit damit diese ausnahme
situation bewältigt werden kann wir
setzen uns als blw event im
verkehrsministerium dafür ein dass die
tank- und raststätte offen bleiben dass
die versorgung der fahrer gewährleistet
bleibt sieht man einen
verkehrsministerium genauso ich gehe
fest davon aus dass wir dort
sonderregelung für die fahrer bekommen
damit die unterwegsversorgung sind
sanitäre anlagen benutzen können was
einfach essentiell ist eine die jungs
ihren job tun können zugang zu sauberen
sanitären anlagen und eine warme
mahlzeit es sind bescheidene wünsche von
denen die täglich für volle
supermarktregale sorgen
[Applaus]
wegen der korona krise sinkt auch die
bereitschaft blut zu spenden das
deutsche rote kreuz schlägt alarm wenn
das so weiter geht dann sind die
reserven bald komplett aufgebraucht
weder notfallpatienten noch chronisch
kranke können dann richtig behandelt
werden
und deshalb gilt wer gesund und fit ist
der kann und da sollte auch zur
blutspende gehen dass carola virus sitzt
das gesundheitssystem unter stress aus
angst vor ansteckung sind die
blutspenden beim roten kreuz in köln in
den letzten wochen deutlich
zurückgegangen
[Musik]
vielen dank dass ihr gekommen sind hier
haben wir haben ja doch in den letzten
tagen das doch spender geht ist das so
ja und da fängt dann direkt mit
bewohnern zusammen mit den kindern viele
sind verunsichert
also in der regel haben hier so an
normalen tagen zwischen 30 und 40
blutspenden
wir hatten jetzt zum beispiel letzte
woche tage da hatten wir nur 20 also das
lernen wir schon deutlich ein erhöhtes
risiko für die spender besteht nicht die
sicherheitsmaßnahmen im
blutspendezentrum wurden trotzdem
deutlich verstärkt wenn jemand reinkommt
wird sofort erstmal fieber gemessen
befragt ob die leute sich wohl fühlen ob
es im moment sich gesund fühlen damit
nicht jemanden 38 temperatur schon mal
alle stationen durchläuft und vielleicht
leute schon angesteckt hat in ganz
deutschland gibt es deutlich weniger
blut spenden als normal nicht überall
ist der rückgang so drastisch wie in
köln wobei es gerade hier eine sehr
begehrte belohnung gibt desinfizieren
das hand gehen
die order dafür macht der referent
meistens ein ganzes jahr vorher schon
das heißt geordnet wurden diese dinge
lange bevor das cola überhaupt
auferstanden ist
das konnte man nicht wissen das ist halt
jetzt zu fall und die leute freuen sich
darüber
der stresstest für unser
gesundheitssystem auch im bereich der
blutspenden hat er angefangen
ja nicht nur das blut ist knapp sie
wissens mehl hefe oder nudeln sind heiß
begehrt aber toilettenpapier ist
momentan gold wert immer wieder wird
betont hamsterkäufe sind nicht nötig das
scheint bei vielen menschen aber leider
immer noch nicht anzukommen
leere regale in supermärkten in
discountern drogerien die klopapier
krise treibt seltsame blüten
nie waren die papierrollen so heiß
begehrt aber wie schlimm steht es
wirklich um toilettenpapier warum kaufen
die deutschen mitten in der korona krise
ausgerechnet so viel klopapier
ich denke nicht nur bei krone auch beim
sommerschlussverkauf erleben wir wenn
menschen ihre einkaufswagen mit
bestimmten gegenständen füllen entsteht
so eine art zwang das kann man auch als
herdentrieb bezeichnet das anderen
menschen nach zu tun
man könnte auch sagen angst ist
ansteckend hier ist auch anstecken droht
deutschland etwa hygiene notstand
wir fragen nach bei einem der führenden
hersteller von hygienepapier in europa
bei s t
das werk in mannheim ist europaweit das
größte des konzerns hier tun sie alles
um die gestiegene nachfrage zu
befriedigen wir haben unsere produktion
erhöht wir haben maßnahmen die in der
planung standen verschoben wir haben
instandhaltungsmaßnahmen verschoben
alles um die anlagen permanent am laufen
zu halten
ein lkw nach dem anderen wird hier
beladen jeder mit tausenden rollen
klopapier
aber warum sind die regale im
einzelhandel dann trotzdem leer
wir produzieren mehr wir liefern mehr
und auch unsere handelspartner liefern
in ihre regale
aber sobald die ware im regal ist wird
sie sofort ab verkauft aufgrund von
hamsterkäufen ist der run auf
toilettenpapier wirklich nötig könnte
corona hier im werk den betrieb
lahmlegen die produktion stoppen
sollten wir trotz aller
vorsichtsmaßnahmen die wir getroffen
haben in unserer produktion einen corona
fall haben so werden wir unsere reserve
schichten im einsatz bringen die wir
gebildet haben
wir haben auch auf der rohstoffseite
vorgesagt unsere lager sind voll
der nachschub läuft unsere lieferanten
haben uns versichert dass sie uns
weiterhin gut versorgen können das
aktuell kein versorgungsengpass bei
toilettenpapier besteht bestätigt auch
der verband deutscher papierfabriken
auch wer hamsterkäufen bislang
widerstanden hat steht jetzt oft vor
leeren regalen schlecht wenn man keine
rolle mehr zuhause hat wenn jeder normal
kauft ist für jeden zu jeder zeit genug
da wir müssen nur aufhören jeder für
sich zu haben es dann im schnitt
verbraucht die der deutsche etwa eine
handelsübliche zehnerpackung im monat
zwei wochen quarantäne soll damit locker
zu schaffen sein sollte man meinen
es gibt berufe da lässt sich der
sicherheitsabstand nicht oder nur sehr
schwer einhalten die polizei zeigt
gerade mehr präsenz und deswegen haben
die beamten auch mehr kontakt zu
potenziell corona erkrankten
polizeistreifen in dienst auch sie kommt
es nun besonders an besteht für mich als
beamter nun eine gesundheitsgefahr wen
hat man bei kontrollen vor sich solche
fragen müssen sich die beamten momentan
stellen
das präsidium bonn auch hier haben sie
sich in den letzten wochen vorbereitet
auf corona schwer zu sagen was bei den
einsätzen kommen können
wenn gefühl gehen dir zu arbeiten an ja
definitiv
ungewohnt heiter mal was nicht was kommt
man weiß nie wer vor ihm steht das nie
wieder reagiert auch kein anspruch oder
nicht aber folglich ist es schon was
neues setzt wolfgang walek ist seit 27
jahren im dienst die einsätze im
angesicht eines unbekannten virus auch
für ihn neu ihre fahrzeuge sind nun mit
sozusagen kroner kids ausgerüstet für
den fall der fälle handschuhe
schutzmasken schutzbrille ein overall
schuberts er wenn hier zu einem einsatz
gerufen werden und wir erkenntnis haben
dass das polizeiliche gegenüber ich sag
jetzt mal infiziert ist ja entweder
wissen wir dass oder die person sagt ich
hab corinna und dann sind wir halt
gezwungen diese sachen oder geraten
diese sachen anziehen
und wenn sie nicht wissen wer da gerade
vor ihnen entsteht und was der
vielleicht vorhat sicherungs abstand
halten
von zwei noch mehr metern und ich sage
jetzt mal vielleicht die person nicht
direkt angucken beim reden vielleicht
ein bisschen auf die person reagieren
wie die person agiert bisher hatten sie
keine corona einsätze aber das kann sich
ja schnell ändern wenn sie angespuckt
oder an gerüstet werden die unsicherheit
bleibt wir wollen natürlich als polizei
gesund bleiben und natürlich geht die
gesundheit von uns von uns polizisten
zunächst vor aber wir kommen in
einsatzsituationen in denen wir
natürlich handeln müssen das werden wir
auch immer tun
wir müssen dann gegebenfalls schauen wie
wir uns danach verhalten wenn wir in
konfliktsituationen waren dass wir
beispielsweise untersucht werden in der
einsatzzentrale ist jetzt zwischen den
beamten immer ein platz frei in den
normalen büros sitzt nur noch ein
kollege weniger straftaten würde es nun
jedoch nicht geben sagen sie aber andere
also ich denke schon dass die
straßenkriminalität zurückgehen dass wir
da vielleicht weniger notrufe bekommen
über randalierer gerade am wochenende
dass da etwas ruhiger wird auf der
straße verkehrsunfallgeschehen
vielleicht etwas zurückgeht
gleichzeitig will man dann andere
einsatzanlässe haben
wenn die leute mit den leuten die decke
auf den kopf wenn sie zu hause sind und
stichwort einbrüche die würden sich
jetzt wohl verlagern weniger in
wohnungen weil die leute ja zu hause
bleiben dafür erwähnte in kitas oder
schulen denn einbrecher wollen wir auch
leben kann man der regel kein legales
ein kommen und gehen quasi auch ihre
arbeit machen
die frage ist was passiert wenn sich
auch polizisten anstecken in bonn haben
sie schon einige wenige corona fälle die
kollegen von betroffenen müssten hier
ein quarantäne
dann so heißt es wird umgeschichtet man
sei landesweit im austausch beamte aus
anderen dienststellen könnten etwa
kommen die einsatzfähigkeit der polizei
bleibe erhalten
sarah tucker die leiterin der zdf rechts
redaktion ist jetzt bei mir und
beantwortet ihre fragen wie sie uns per
mail geschickt haben
die erste ist von liebe wir sind eine
gmbh und durch den geschäftsführer wurde
angeboten auch im home office arbeiten
zu gehen allerdings unterstellt er das
nicht die volle leistung gebracht wird
und aus diesem grund will er nur 80
prozent des gehaltes zahlen ist das
rechtens
das geht nicht also wenn man aus dem
home office arbeitet arbeitet man auch
voll
es sei denn man vereinbart dass man 80
prozent arbeitet aber man kann das nicht
man kann nicht automatisch davon
ausgehen nur wenn man nicht im büro sind
ist würde man weniger arbeiten und wenn
man seine volle arbeitskraft anbietet
und es keinen anderen grund gibt dann
wird man auch voll bezahlt so ist also
nicht rechtens dann schreibt ti ist ein
umzug ein wichtiger grund sich mit mehr
als zwei personen in der öffentlichkeit
zu bewegen ja ein umzug ist ja arbeit
also zumindest für diejenigen die bei
dem umzug mit arbeiten und die neuen
regelungen zum den kontakt
beschränkungen kontakt verboten zählen
vor allem aufs private ab das heißt wenn
bei einem umzug mehrere personen
arbeiten und anpacken dann ist das
weiterhin zulässig
ok also wenn ich jetzt auch ein umzug in
fernerer zukunft geplant habe kann das
alles so bleiben die fernere zukunft ist
ehrlich gesagt in diesen tagen sich sehr
schwer vorauszusagen
weil sich die ereignisse so schnell und
die frage ist welche regelung haben wenn
zwei wochen ich kann nur sagen für den
moment habe man umziehen oder umschreibt
handwerker fahren oft zusammen
im auto habe ich eine rechtliche
grundlage meinen chef aufzufordern das
zu ändern
der chef hat grundsätzlich eine
fürsorgepflicht dafür dass sich die
arbeitnehmer nicht infizieren und
natürlich ist diese abstandsregelung die
wir im privaten anhalt anderthalb zwei
meter sollte auch im beruflichen
ermöglicht werden trotzdem die aktuellen
regelung zielen vor allem darauf ab dass
wir nicht mehr im privaten in großen
gruppen uns aufhalten
deshalb kann man den chef bitten
vielleicht atemmasken zur verfügung zu
stellen
desinfektionsmittel vielleicht kann sie
auch anders aufteilen im auto aber im
richtigen anspruch hat man nicht okay
dann schreibt nicole breitner ich
erwarte ein kind und muss jetzt zu 100
prozent in kurzarbeit gehen habe ich bei
der berechnung des elterngeldes
finanzielle einbußen zu erwarten weil
das elterngeld berechnet sich ja immer
aus dem einkommen vom vorjahr und da gab
es ja noch kein corona und keine
kurzarbeit und kriegt das ist gut
nadine steilen schreibt wie weit es sich
rechtlich und finanziell wenn ich jetzt
auf grund der ausgangs beschränkung
nicht aus einer mietwohnung ins
eigenheim umziehen kann muss ich dann
weiter miete und kredite bedienen man
muss weiter miete und kredite zahlen man
kann natürlich immer ins gespräch gehen
aber man kann auch aktuell weiterhin
umziehen also sollte das problem gelöst
werden indem der umzug an war vollzogen
wird und ansonsten gibt es keine
rechtlichen ansprüche da hilft nur mit
dem vermieter sprechen weil natürlich
viele aktuell auch in einer finanziellen
notlage sein werden und mit
mietausfällen jetzt unabhängig von dem
umzug zu rechnen ist und da hilft es nur
wirklich mit dem vermieter ins gespräch
zu gehen
ok also immer im kontakt bleiben franke
ja sarah tucker und unser khurana
kompakt finden sie täglich auch im
internet auf youtube und zwar auf dem
kanal der zdf heute außerdem können sie
uns weiter ihre fragen an unsere
experten schicken von denen wir dann
einige hier im studio beantworten werden
die e mail adresse dafür ist corona
kompakte zdf.de